Policy has been passed overwhelmingly
for innovation agenda.
We even with the opposition of the
Republican leadership,
oh,
we had a majority of the Republicans
voting with us.
So from a policy standpoint is passed
the congress,
it was called the compete act.
It's paying for it.
That is a problem for the president of
the United States.
They don't want to pay any bills.
And so,
um,
uh,
these investments in research and
development and education that are
essential to the innovation that our
country needs need to be paid for.
Uh,
we,
we put some money of that into the
supplemental calling an emergency,
put it in the supplemental.
Not Enough,
but a signal that science and research
and development is essential to
innovation.
And we intend to follow through.